hello everyone
come to simulation I'm your host Alan
Saki and today we have the pleasure
sitting down with Mako cup Island hello
thank you yeah thank you for joining us
thank you for having me we're gonna be
talking about the power of video games
it's super exciting yes at a time when
the game developer conference is
happening right here in San Francisco
right now just a few blocks down the
street yeah and the kills backgrounds
perfect for this he really cares about
utilizing the video the video game
medium to try and better humanity in
many different ways and we're gonna be
talking about that today your
backgrounds great yeah you got a
master's degree in game design from
Carnegie Mellon great great you versi
went to intern with oculus over at
facebook again awesome very futuristic
stuff and VR will talk touch on that and
currently game design at Sony
Interactive the other PlayStation that's
my life story
yeah well let's let's talk about the
roots so the roots of the story are born
in India yes yes and then how did you
like go through the process of like
becoming who you are today like how did
you decide to my personal origin story
yeah yeah yeah I mean before before
India in fact I I had the unique
opportunity of kind of growing up in
three different continents so a part of
my childhood was in the Bay Area so age
1 to 10 was in Santa Clara in fact Wow
so born India and then came here what
attend Santa Clara 10 to 12 in the UK
which is the second continent whoa and
then back to India
so it was definitely an interesting
childhood with a lot of varied
perspectives and I guess it just it's it
gives you a lot of different lenses to
look at people and places and cultures
and interesting things like that but
yeah growing up I was always drawn to
just art in general I was I was a museum
enthusiast read a ton of books yeah and
I think growing up you also
India is an extremely conservative
culture and a lot of the decisions that
you make at the age of 18 aren't
necessarily with the thought processes
the thought process of asking yourself
what truly makes you happy yeah
in a sense that almost came a little
later so a large part of my
undergraduate education was just sort of
going with the flow and doing the safe
things to do so I got a degree in
computer science I decide to make the
move to the US the Carnegie Mellon what
what was the reason that you left India
to come here yeah well like I said like
I was saying so I got a grant an
undergraduate degree in computer science
which was back in India and I knew I
wanted to be creative I knew I wanted to
work in a medium world I was able to
tell stories you know to express ideas
emotions
yeah evoke evoke I guess evoking emotion
in people was ultimately my goal and
that sort of married with the background
in computer science almost sort of the
path forwards unveiled itself very
organically in a sense yeah I was a huge
video gamer my entire life
and that sort of led to the decision of
like the United States is is is where
the magic happens
particularly for video games as as an
emergent medium there's that one company
that I recently learned about called
Tencent mm-hmm yeah oh yeah it's I think
like there are a Lourdes company is
really interested in the Chinese market
and that particular organization has
holdings in a lot of different American
video game studios like Activision King
so they're yeah they're taking over the
world I I was reading about what their
yeah holdings and yeah it's very
interesting definitely go to Wikipedia
and look up $0.10 and just go read about
them they're like 150 billion dollar
yeah a year come company or that might
be in you
I think might be or yeah it might be but
in terms of us all or whatever but
they're very they have their hands in a
lot of videogame stuff as well I mean
another sort of interesting thing about
China as and as an emergent economy is
that the Chinese economy has of course
traditionally been manufacturing based
and I think there's a strong desire
based on conversations I've had with
people for China to be an emergent
leader in creative in something in
something new and something that is a
part of the future as opposed to being a
delivery center so there's a lot of
investment in things like virtual
reality and emerging technologies in
general yes okay so as you're growing up
you know you mentioned that the culture
is conservative and I also feel like
within a lot of the United States we
still don't do a really excellent job at
helping children figure out what they're
really passionate about at a young age
and then get them into that field of
study and that that play of life yeah as
early we kind of also also push people
through this university system generals
figured out there spend lots of money
doing that some people just don't figure
it out there some people go into work
when they're 22 and they don't like it
right away
so this it's very we got a we got a lot
of work to do in that sector to make it
better but you specifically you know
this also impresses me you're also an
author this is very cool
Lawson transition and so maybe you let's
tell us about this this is this was very
fascinating when I was learning about
this from you of course of course lost
in transition is sort of my magnum opus
I suppose it's the way I like to
describe it is Eat Pray Love meets
boyhood to a certain extent so it's a
story of discovery and it's a
coming-of-age story about sexual
discovery through
through the lens of travel yeah and it
was kind of inspired by by two by two
large events in my life one was of
course sort of the aspect of growing up
as someone who identifies as a gay man
in an extremely homophobic country that
that was that phase of my life was
certainly not easy and I think it left
in me a desire to have that story be
expressed but the actual impetus in the
trigger to begin penning that novel was
when I embarked on this three-month sort
of soul-searching expedition to Europe
and it started off as it started it
started off as a side project for the
duration of that trip and it just sort
of grew and grew and I think by the end
of that trip I knew that this is going
to be a much larger project and let's
say our travel blog yeah so yeah I mean
it took around a year year and a half to
actually go from inception to deal with
the publisher the could this
coming-of-age in love and understanding
oneself this across the world we were
just discussing about it throughout the
lens of Education now we're discussing
about it through the lens of sexuality
this was crazy when we were riding
together on on Monday up up from the
peninsula to the city that both in India
and in Kenya there is very strict
homophobic cultural norms and policies
in law to where you can be imprisoned
that the this is very important to
communicate what tell us about this yeah
it's it was an interesting story about
like I guess how have we met we met in
an uber ride and that that is for it was
it's just funny how fleeting
transactions in in the city
whole thing's great friendships but yeah
so India is India surprisingly backwards
in a lot of its social values in just in
terms of I guess acceptance of people
who are not part of the cultural
majority as as the public sees sees us
so by the the actual legal section that
you're referring to is something that in
the indian constitution inherited from
the British there was a clause in the
Constitution of Britain called section
377 that was sort of rolled into India's
Constitution in 1947 when India became
its its own country and so by by law
individuals can be jailed for up to as
as high as I think 10 to 15 years if
there's photographic evidence produced
of homosexual activity
I think the section 377 has sort of like
apart from the legal ramifications and
just having having that messaging to
young boys and girls growing up that you
your identity is is such a flaw in in
the workings of our society that we can
actually put you in jail yeah apart
apart from like the legal implications
of that there's also any any notion of a
movement in India of of a of an LGBT
movement and a community sort of ends up
being a conversation about the law which
is which is in a way in a sense
inherently and an in humanistic approach
to a movement and rather than about
thyself
correct correct exhibits important to
also want to change the law as well yeah
totally totally it's it's just it's
unfortunate how we've we sort of we've
been unable to overcome that barrier as
if now I
sort of elevate that conversation to be
a lot more about the individual and the
individuals journey through a dollar
sensor people in the West really need to
know about this really because a lot of
people here don't realize what is given
to us and the simple notion that someone
in high school that's you know figuring
themselves out has a photograph snapped
of them and then spends 10 or 15 years
in jail because of that that's that's
not a principle that I think that
society should be grounding itself into
so Ron did you know that about across
the world that there are still places
that are really just honing in on
people's sexuality and just trying to
keep it the way that man and woman only
and that's it yeah I'm well aware of the
problems that we face on this planet and
oppression and something wanting to
control us no doubt yeah yeah I think in
it's it's awful when you look at it
again just from that legal stand just
the legal implications of what could
happen to you based on your sexuality
yeah but having said all that the other
side of that problem is in a sense even
though we have these these sort of
draconian laws that exist like the word
the word gay doesn't still really exist
in the conscience of the public yeah so
when I say homophobic I it I guess what
the image that is concerned in my head
is probably very different than the
image that is conjured in someone who
grew up in the West yeah so when I say
homophobic I mean completely ignorant of
the notion of what that means of the
idea of being gay as an important part
of one's identity it is not a part of
public discourse and versus being just
completely against it knowing about it
and being against it versus not even
doing that it can be an identity of
somebody's precisely yeah yeah yeah and
I think what that does is it leaves a
certain gap in idea it there are no sort
of cultural and societal inlets for one
to truly discover who they are and
that's what the book is the book is
about like how sort of discovery of new
spaces through the lens of traveling can
provide those inlets yeah and how see
having new experiences with new new
types of people helps it helps the
protagonist embrace himself truly yeah
that's a really beautiful way to
describe it yeah traveling experiencing
new cultures in the world helps you
really identify yourself and figure
yourself out and hopefully enables
hopefully writings like this and more
will enable us to have more open minded
conversations about where we should head
as a society so this is this is really
cool I'm really happy that you're an
author they lost in transition available
on its it's available on Amazon it's
available on Amazon dot
Indian website phone yeah but
unfortunately not amazon.com I'm working
on that hopefully we will get it on
amazon.com very soon
oh so if we have any anyone who's
listening to this right now give me a
call publisher but yeah I think I just
think it's it's it's an important story
not just of course because because I
wrote it but it's a reflection of a
voice that a lot of people need to hear
I gave a podcast recently and I had an
extremely hard warming message that I
received on Facebook from a young man he
was 16 years old amazing and he was
saying having read the book that
inspired him to come out to his parents
and what I was it was just it's it's
hard to think of we all know that coming
out is a significant event but living in
our
barrier bubble where I guess over time
we've kind of become desensitized to how
huge that event can be in in a person's
life and to know that I was able to help
very hard and there's this crazy
opposite to that as well which so many
people talk about meaning that a parent
or parents being super super hyper
liberal and Western will do things like
will do things like straight up say that
oh I'm you know three my child's three
years old or my child's five years old
and they have some sort of of a
inclination of being you know sexually
inclined towards boys or girls or that
they have transgender inclinations and
and I think that's also kind of you know
that's basically on this complete
opposite side of the conversation from
coming out we ask that you almost guide
your child to one of these thoughts and
and so III simultaneously just like to
bring in that aspect of the conversation
because so many people do bring that up
yeah as well so it's it's so for a
longer discussion but in in general all
of these voices at the table let's let's
make them heard and let's help
children's self actualize into the world
through education like we were
describing earlier as well as their
sexuality and yeah be open-minded
I can I can drink it back let's drink to
that
we received a package in the meanwhile
that was the knock knock on the door
it's good we got a package in they may
not have heard that you could have said
nothing and nobody would have known
anything we got it we got a little long
yeah USPS package exciting will get open
it up see what it is it's light bulbs
it's light bulbs yeah for our studio
exciting so okay so that was our bit in
in lost in transition and now let's talk
about okay we have game design is
becoming such a and it's good to hear
about your background being like art
creativity wanting to you know going to
computer science in India and then
making the journey to Carnegie Mellon
for the Masters now as you're as you're
going through this process game design
and development taking this you know
this road to being coming and elevating
medium not just we were talking about
this earlier but using guns to kill
people and that being it we're over that
or so over that we've moved so far away
from that now I'm into completely new
and beautiful areas and we'll talk about
maybe more of those areas soon but let's
talk about the actual nitty gritty
engineering side of things quick so what
does one have to learn so computer
science and then unity this a whole like
unreal is one of the engines that you
can use like what are these engines and
how do they help in the games what link
what programming languages are they
written in what aspects of design do you
need like animation design and that kind
of stuff how do these things come
together to make yes yeah yeah game game
development as as a field and as a
practice is unique in that it is it is a
marriage of both sides of the band like
left as one
as one calls it like left side left
brain thinking versus right brain
thinking so there are many doubts into
the industry so we have people who come
in from the computer science side there
are a lot of people who come in from a
visual art side that is they're focused
on things like animation drawing
sketching concept are things an
extremely important part of the video
game development process in kind of
aligning the team's
vision on the project just having having
a poster that is kind of like your
shining North Star for a project is
super important so there are lots of
different routes in into the into the
industry - through computer - through
computer science and even though I'm not
so my role is that of a designer so my
job is to kind of find the fun in in in
and find the fun find the fun yes that's
that's that's the one-line description
for my job a lot of people a lot of
people kind of struggle to wrap their
heads around what a designer does
because like most people can can sort of
think of okay the code is written by the
programmers and the artists create the
visuals so what does the designer do and
a designer's role is to ultimately think
of the player and to make that
experience be as enriching as possible
and you can't really theorize fun fun
must be experienced in order for the
team to then take that vision and run
with it so where my computer science
science background comes in is in
actually building out quick rough dirty
prototypes which have no high visual
fidelity involved but just has all of
the building blocks and off the game
sort of stubbed in it's that we can
experience it and evaluate it as a team
it's often said that games are iterated
into existence yeah and so you build a
lot of those fundamental iteration
iterations of it and then people will
you'll go through a period of testing to
see where the fun
it comes from yeah and then you'll pay
attention combine a couple of those
funds together into the product but the
way I like to visualize it is when you
start off a project a game can be
anything like there's there's an entire
universe of a possibility space that is
possible and it's the designers job to
kind of guide the team through that
possibility space towards a particular
point helping creative leaders make
decisions that are right for the player
that are right for the game and
eventually hopefully leads to the best
part of possible and then how do you
make these iterations so what is the
code that you're using and yeah tell us
a little bit about that of course so we
in our studio we use a game engine
called Unreal Engine Unreal Engine is
maintained by Epic Games which is a
studio based sort of North Carolina I
believe they're responsible for games
like for tonight Paragon very successful
studio what is the engine yeah so unreal
Unreal Engine supports two different
kinds two different levels of code
creation if you will
it supports C++ which is what our
engineers use to handle very low-level
hard problems like rendering and how how
pixels move on screen really so that is
that is the deeply technical side of
engine development and can this be
something like this this these
parameters of pixels will move to this
location on the plane that we've created
and then you'll guide it there that's
the yeah something okay well you can
think of it this way so typically most
game engines offered a sort of a scene
creation kit so places where the actual
layout the environment is laid out and
you kind of have a virtual camera so you
need to now take
the virtual camera you need to take all
of the objects that are in the scene and
that needs to translate to an image yeah
with with which is rendering the right
objects at the right time yes so this is
this is like the deep end of the beast
it's so cool
so as in as you're moving across the
plane to the location all of the houses
and trees and all these good things that
are in the environment are changing the
way that you because your move you're
moving the in the screen what you're
seeing is moving kind of that virtual
camera is being moved to a different
location yeah that's so fascinating oh
yeah I love it yeah and again I guess
one important thing to remember is games
run into your time so these these images
that are produced are entirely dynamic
because they are controlled by a player
this is like and therefore poses a
hugely different set of technical
challenges than let's say rendering
rendering a frame as a Pixar movie would
yeah yes those those are static images
that will always be the same no matter
how many times you experience so that's
sort of like the deep under belly of the
beast if you will fortunately those are
hard technical problems that I don't
have to worry about I have people we
have people who are much smarter than
myself that were londo engine is just
available for people it's up in any
leverage and and that whole engine has
to be dynamically able to you know the
player moves here and that that shifts
and so all these all of that math needs
to register as it's being processed on
the fly like that it's very fascinating
this yeah you said there's two engines
though right did you say correctly I
said there were two there are two
different logic flow creation tools if
you will one so all of the things that I
that we just discussed is a part of the
engine so this is something that a
developer will probably tweak but not
build from scratch
they are largely puss-puss is how they c
c++ is still the primary language that's
used for moving pixels on a screen okay
where my role on the other hand is more
thinking about the game so we're we're
thinking about we're scripting things
like interactions that is i how does
when the player moves their hand in the
virtual world in the real world how does
that map to any interaction in the in
the virtual world so all of that kind of
scripting happens at a higher level
through a different kid different logic
flow different logic so there's the
logic flow of the Unreal Engine and the
C++ moving the pixels on screen and then
there's also the the logic flow of when
you actually trigger a movement on your
controller as the user experiencing the
process what do they in the vid what do
they see on the actual and how can how
can you maximize that for fun and yeah
that's right yes so all of that happens
on using what is called a visual
scripting tool with unreal it's called a
blueprint blueprint yeah way the way you
can like try and visualize it is you
have you can think of it as a flowchart
so you have you have normed that a
designer or a creator can place in an
editor and you have a control flow that
triggers through so you can branch on
that control flow you can you can loop
on the on that control flow okay things
like that nice it's blueprints visual
editor nodes yeah that's this that's
cool okay yeah so it's something it's
something that a lot of different people
can collaborate with easily because it
does not require a background in
computer science mmm it's okay yeah okay
we were just discussing this before we
started it's it's a really interesting
time for the industry simply because
these tools are now available due to the
public so anyone from
small village in India to two big cities
in Africa can potentially be picking up
these tools and begin to express
themselves and their idea without having
to solve very hard technical challenges
and just focus on the game so then they
can use the the visual the blueprint
they can use that with an unreal and
then they would they would still need a
body to be able to get it the C++ in to
actually be able to engineer that into
existence but they can at least get the
blueprint out as well okay cool
now okay so let's so with with this new
transition of games this is it that was
a really good foundation we have a lot
of gaming you were at oculus for a while
now what is what are we doing with
virtual reality because it seems like
virtual reality is its own thing and
then video gaming itself is still on the
in in three dimensions but on a
two-dimensional screen but then some
some consoles actually have VR sets as
well that you can play it with it and
then there's of course the VR sets
outside of the console play so then now
is that it's that's a console itself now
yeah so yeah we're how do you decide to
build in VR or build on the console
without VR and if you decide to build
for both how do you do that all this
yeah yeah there's there's a whole lore
done back there for sure but I guess
broadly you can kind of think of gaming
in VR as a very small part of what VR is
capable of so when one thinks of a game
what comes to mind is a sense of being
challenged right essentially where
you're given a certain set of tools and
you're expected to demonstrate your
skill over a series of obstacles that
transpire over time potentially with a
narrative or story in the back
that's that's usually how people
visualize games but what we're sort of
learning with VR is that that structure
that I just described to you may not
even be the best utilization of that
medium we we can build VR games that are
that are deeply challenging to a player
and hard games but there's an entire set
of experiences that are a little bit
more accessible to people and
foundationally what has made that
possible is because VR gives you a lot
of different tools use there's there's a
limited amount that you can do with this
controller right here yes you you have
you can map buttons to certain character
actions yes and that's sort of the most
you can do with the controller there
because there's also limited amount of
those but then yes you can one of them
can open up a wheel of other options and
things like that yeah
the point being there's this separation
between the player and the virtual world
what VR do that integration is just so
much tighter yeah and that opens up just
a completely different set of
possibilities in terms of how you would
interact with the world that's cool so
we can we can do more than punching and
kicking and actually in the virtual
world in there in 3d that gives you so
much more than being outside of it with
a controller controlling the character
inside of it yeah yeah in the industry
we like to refer to them as verbs verbs
the player executes below the neck and
above the neck verbs like below the neck
verbs being things like shooting and
punching and kicking uh-huh and above
the neck being things like feeling
and emotive decision-making yeah that's
cool I like that below the neck and
above the neck yeah especially in gaming
that makes a lot of sense schemes are
usually separated by that like is that
unlike action and stuff or is it um like
close quarter combat stuff or is it more
of the well I actually really thought
that what you said the beginning was
really interesting about Ronda to evoke
emotion in people yeah yeah totally I
mean I think VR has opened its has
opened up the the medium of interactive
experiences do so much more than just
being experiences that challenge players
and expect a demonstration of the skill
set we can now make experiences that are
more about wish fulfillment and fantasy
fulfillment yes what would it would be
like to walk in the moon yes what would
it what would it be like to have to have
a dinosaur roam past me when when when
I'm when I'm in prehistoric land or
let's go into the molecules or the
double helix of DNA yeah there's so many
cool places that the giant potential for
take us so giant so I think that VR is
very good at transporting you to do a
different world because it's so
experiential yes so that's sort of like
on the entertainment side even the
education yes yes yeah there's an
entirely different set of potential VR
applications that are not intended with
the sole purpose of being entertainment
we are seeing VR experiences that are
now being used to treat symptoms like
PTSD yeah helping helping patients
overcome things like phantom pain in the
and the amputated limbs the
prescriptions from doctors legally to
play video games to help with ADHD
instead of pharmaceuticals this is just
mind-blowing it's Achille interactive
labs one of our very close friends Adam
gazelian and Eddie Mair Tucci from from
the from the platform I mean this is
this is a whole new era I love it
games utilized for the not just
entertainment purposes but for
maximizing human potential in many ways
yeah that's right there's there's a
tremendous power that comes out of just
virtual worlds yeah and the manner in
which we create our virtual worlds will
help us behave and perform better in the
real world is how I like to think of VR
and its potentials yes I am so
interested in excited about that so why
don't you tell us about a couple like
projects that are going on that I within
Sony can you can you identify or can you
like identify a couple of them that are
happening across the studio and yeah
yeah absolutely one of the games that
one of our sister Studios is working on
is a game called concrete genie this is
a trailer that can be checked out on on
YouTube we'll put the link in the bio
yeah and it's it's it's a really great
example of everything that we were just
discussing in terms of elevating games
to be a medium that is that is truly a
medium for creative expression and so
fundamentally the game in the game the
player controls a young boy who has who
just has a wonderful imagination and he
loves to draw and sketch and he creates
these he creates these landscapes in his
in his sketchbook but one fine day he
discovers this magic paintbrush that he
can now use to project his imagination
onto the real world so the marks that he
was creating on his sketch by
now these beautiful masterpiece
starlings out in the real world and
stuff above that is he can now also
create these magical creatures that
inhabit these virtual these environments
that that he can create and the
underpinning narrative thread do all of
this is he's he's also bullied
relentlessly in school so he these these
creatures that he paints become his
virtual companions and through
interaction with the creatures he learns
he learns to understand his bullies and
his bullies learn to understand him
we're all very very excited to see that
game come out hopefully in the near
future that again it just seems like so
philosophically driven it's driven
towards foking emotion of how do kids
work together with their bullies to
understand one another and how can one
become creative and make other sketchpad
come to life and then that life
interacts with the world around to those
creatures it's it just seems like you
know this is the future of video games
this games that are useful future game
design is games that are you know useful
in many ways past just the idea of the
shoulders down I guess it it boils down
to just this the simple thought that by
showing people something you might
forget that but by interacting with
something yeah actually practicing
something you are so much more likely to
retain that message that message with
you so yeah interactivity is is the key
at least we in the games industry
believe that unlocks a well of human
experience yeah do you thin as way more
important to repattern behavior than
just intellectualizing something when
you actually put it into practice
experientially
now what do you think about
this has been very interesting to me
because you know things like eSports are
exploding now people are training on
certain games whether it be Super Smash
Bros or Call of Duty or Halo or League
of Legends or dota or Starcraft there's
so many games that are now being played
on the high level of like thousands tens
of thousands of dollars hundreds of
thousands of dollars in terms of prize
money and sponsorship and teams are
being assembled sponsors are coming in
all this stuff and they're playing
really high level I mean it's turned
into kind of like what the high level
chess players of the world we're doing
but now this is so crazy because as
we've seen these these these
reinforcement learning algorithms these
these these deep neural networks that
are able to figure out how how to play a
game better than humans happened in
chess happens and go happens in DotA now
so this is again open a I made a bot
that beat some of the world's leading
players at dota it's a very complicated
game multivariate lots of strategy going
on lots of immediate M interactions and
analysis of variables that need to be
happening and there was curious where
you see the future going with you know
with where did where does AI take it
take into account these but there's the
ability to program a really strong up a
bot to play in the eSports arena but
also we were talking about how things
like machine learning can help video
game developers and designers get really
good
the repetitive things that they need to
do it can just take that to control that
and finish that so we can move on to
doing the things that we're good at the
creative stuff so it's kind of those two
different like angles to it where do you
see it where you see it going yeah
again like hole or done back there for
short I think it's it's just it's also
worth pointing out like
the the beauty of interactive media in
this regard if we were just talking
about things like fantasy fulfillment
that are not necessarily about
challenging players and like we can
within the same brushstroke we can also
now discuss something that is hyper
competitive and all of these experiences
fit within the world of games and I just
think that's it's it's beautiful and
it's worth it's worth calling out yeah
but yeah I mean esports esports
is it's it's great to see esports kind
of coming of age in many ways I have
myself personally never been a
competitive gamer but it's it's it's a
it's an important it's a nut I think a
lot of people are trying to crack like
how do we create a system that is so
deep that it has the staying power that
a true sport does a way to sort of think
about it is physical sport exists have
existed for so long and have the staying
power that they do because this the
fundamental systems that they are
grounded in are are systems of human
nature like our systems of the human
body and physics and gravity and things
such as that
so that and our subjective kind of like
infinite variations the human mind is an
is a very very important part of the
sport like an athlete will tell you with
that it's most of most of his most of
his of her or his or her training comes
in the mind and not so much in the body
so can we create game systems and rule
sets that are so complex and deep that
almost as deep as as the as the rules of
nature if you go yeah so I guess that's
one way of looking at it I think a large
part of it is also in terms of setting
up infrastructure in order in order for
people to really take this seriously as
as a sport I think if you were to pull
the public at this point you would still
not necessarily have a lot of people
identify
and eSport as being an equivalent career
path or as potentially noble a
profession as competing in a real sport
I guess what I'm saying is what the
industry desires is kind of the
elevation of the stature of of eSports
and I'm starting to see that we're
starting to see university support
varsity programs and have scholarships
for competitive players and who have
achieved success in high school or in
eSports Wow we're it's fast becoming a
legitimate career path yeah a risky one
of course then again anything worth
doing is risky is it not it is what
universities are I'm I'm not entirely
sure I think I believe the University of
Texas offers UTA some universities in
California as well like I said I'm not a
hyper competitive gamer but it's
starting to see a recognition by the
mainstream public if you will cool what
do you think about potential for
artificial intelligence to come in and
you can't even tell if you're playing
against a bot or if you play as a player
yeah yeah we're just kidding how like
every every eSports competition is
potentially could potentially become a
Turing test word you're guessing you're
always guessing whether you're saying
you think a human or a robot yeah humans
competing against robots is is is one
way of is one way of looking at it well
I guess would I'm personally far more
interested in is how do we use AI to
enrich non-competitive experiences we
were just talking about VR this is so
incredibly relevant to be art AI in in
non-player characters simply because
until now we we were viewing AI only
only in terms of supporting clear
competence it's like how intelligent do
we need to make this character to
challenge you while he's trying to kill
you and you are trying to kill him yeah
and that was all we needed to worry
about when we thought about AI
like dynamically adjusting the level of
competitiveness towards the player skill
right right what is now with with
mediums like VR and experiences that are
aspiring to be more than simply
challenging on a skill level we need
these characters inner worlds to have
inner lives of their own
they must have wants and desires and
goals in order for them to be
interesting enough that players will
care for them
I can we it's it's often said that
characters might be V R's killer app
it's like every medium every medium
desires this one killer application that
sort of propels that medium into the
mainstream and I think there's a growing
school of thought that characters are
that killer app for VR elaborate a bit
more teach us about that yeah well
because we are so experiential just the
the ability to exist in a virtual
environment is is incomplete unless you
have other other people and other
characters characters with you so I
guess you can sort of like see that
dividing into two genres if you all
their social vr which is which is
oriented around experiences where you
are actually with other people yeah and
you're experiencing things with a friend
so I'm a character in your character and
we're in the same multiplayer cut around
yeah so these could just be things like
chat halls yeah are are even potentially
even games the word you're both
cooperating on a mission potentially and
that mission could also be work you
could be in like a virtual work
environment you could be working
together from across the world stuff
like that yeah totally totally
enterprise VR is yeah certainly it's
certainly something that people are
trying to start to inculcate into their
into their work routines but air-driven
characters is sort of almost on the
opposite side of what we were discussing
so how do we how do we have
single-player experiences with
characters that you
you have a relationship with it's
there's a wonderful experience one of
the early VR experience is called Henry
that a lot of people on the team that I
work with right now worked on back then
and it's Henry and it's a very simple
experience about a hedgehog who is who
wants who desires a friend because and
he likes to hug people
sounds like sonic Knuckles bird yeah
Henry likes to hug people bird no one
wants to hug him back because he's a
porcupine with with different words that
come out of his body
it's a lovely experience that can be
tried on the app for the store but
there's this moment where he makes eye
contact with you and that that moment
was for me the the WoW moment for VR and
when it wasn't making eye contact in the
world beforehand and then when you're in
the world then it finally made eye
contact you and then you looked at Henry
yeah and that was a wall moment because
it's already a WoW moment to look at
other human's eyes right you know
sometimes we're not even looking at each
other's eyes because we it takes a lot
of cognitive power to come up with a
really complex thought sometimes and we
don't it looking at someone else's eyes
can be a little bit it's a lot to also
perceive someone's eyes while trying to
come up with a thought sometimes people
don't look into one's eyes because it
might be disingenuous coming from them
that's that is very true yeah I just
wanted to throw that in there yeah yeah
it's easier to lie when you're not
looking at someone's eyes without a
doubt yeah but a lot of you also you
have to understand people as well they
they're not aware that they're lying
even if they but they believe in
something that might be a falsehood and
sometimes you just have that effect
where the whole the whole thing with
truth and fall
is very complex yep we're most of us are
terribly full of [ __ ] Ronnie what about
what about a what about a virtual world
where you're looking at someone's eyes
and that's another thing yeah this could
also be in fact of virtual world you
know our soul it could be really just
operating this meat puppet that I am and
that's why I think that's what's
happening to us right now there's gonna
be a revelation so to speak be beyond
what might be written in you know Holy
Scripture but that's what I think is
happening right now what what we are
creating is only what we have already
been but that's again I could possibly
I'm also full of [ __ ] in my works
because this is just we were created by
the universe now we're creating
universes with these puppets okay let's
let's walk let's walk in to kill down
some of our simulation questions all
right so yeah let's what do you think is
the meaning or the purpose of life wow
this this conversation is escalated very
quickly didn't it I I think the meaning
and purpose of the beauty about that
question is that it is it is entirely up
to the individual and like the fact that
the fact that human beings are able to
create purpose from from nothing from
from nothing that is inherently given to
them is the beauty of our species so I
guess I I guess I object to the idea of
that question by of there being of there
needing to be a singular defining human
purpose
because that's that's that is the
journey of life isn't it let's say that
there are a couple meanings or purposes
to life the couple that we really need
to focus on in order to sustain
collectively in order to sustain
collectively our-our and to kind of
elevate our society what are the
questions that we need to answer um what
would what would that meaning or purpose
be
what would we hone in has the meanings
and purposes in order to sustain
collectively and elevate the species
yeah I think I guess the collection of
knowledge comes to mind having that is a
human purpose that is is inherently
human like I think there's there's a
curiosity drive that exists in in all of
us and is a useful purpose for us to
share because it then allows us to
define our own purposes
assembling a body of knowledge and
abortive knowledge that encompasses
reality and being able to explain our
reality I suppose I think opens opens
people up to then define use that
knowledge to define their purpose yeah
yeah exactly we create this massive of
wisdom and knowledge intelligence that
we now have and then we can tap into
that and use it to find meaning and
purpose individually and collectively
okay
how about what is something that you
believe that nobody else believes to be
true or very very few people believe to
be true what do I believe
that very few people believe to be true
I suppose I don't necessarily know if
this is a viewpoint that a lot of people
shed or do not sure but the idea that
fantasy can make a better reality I
guess yeah I think people separate our
those those two I I don't necessarily
know if people believe that their their
fantasies and their imaginations hold
any sway on the real lives or should
hold any sway on their real lives and I
think being being the power of the
imagination I suppose is one way of
describing that yeah I suppose the idea
that your personal fantasies will help
make your reality better if you I I do I
do and it's very fun that it loops right
back into what we're talking about
design totally it does not only the
fantasies that our mind comes up with
but that we construct how and it really
works with engineering software Ron and
I are going to the engineering software
conference the Congress on the future of
engineering software Coface engineers
and designers that use software to
simulate something in a virtual world
gives them tremendous insight into what
it will actually tangibly feel like
operate like in the real world which is
why we do it in the virtual world first
and make all the tweaks and then we put
it into the real world so that way you
don't put it into the real world and it
falls apart or what have you
yeah well I guess that's only one way of
looking at it but I support I guess what
I was trying to say was a little bit
more encompassing than necessarily
engineering or virtual reality but but
the idea that the your your inner models
of the inner models of your mind and the
models of reality that you hold can help
transform the world
so like your your personal fantasies by
fine to see I suppose I mean your
version of the world or the version of
the world that exists in your brain when
when that has a voice and when you are
able to express that that can then
transform other people's reality exactly
so what were the vision that you have a
better future to be able to then go and
build it executed into the world can
help other people live a healthier and
happier more fulfilled life so to take
what is forming inside of this mind so
often I can't even go anymore without
looking around me on the streets
wherever I go and think about how can I
make these systems better yeah yeah okay
how about are we alone in the cosmos are
we alone in the cosmos I I think that's
that's a that's a a question that I
don't know about I'm super qualified to
answer but it seems like my
understanding of the body of science
that exists right now is we actually
don't have a very we don't have tools to
answer that question yet because that in
in a sense that is a probability
assessment of the origins of life and if
we if we understand the origin of life
in in our in our planet we can then
attempt to go about ascribing that
probability in different environments in
different stars and galaxies in the
universe but we don't necessarily know
the other have that a little bit with
the Drake Equation these different
formulas where we can put together the
average amount of earth-like planets
that have formed around star systems and
then whether or not they've hit these
different like asteroids have hit them
or if they if maybe only microbial life
developed and nothing more there's
always a difference yeah well I mean the
problem that a lot of those models is
masoom that life must be organic
mmm what do you think life could be like
if it's not organic what would it be
like we're not like deep deep in defense
simulation conversations okay I'm I'm
sure there are ways non-synthetic life
could rather synthetic life could exist
and and be non-organic don't tell us
what what do you envision it like well
it's I mean we were discussing
simulations in a I guess in in in a
humorous manner but it's it is entirely
possible for us to if we have the
computational ability and if we have an
understanding of the human mind then we
could potentially simulate a human brain
in your leading us into the next
question which is are we in a computer
simulation well I guess if we had the
tools to answer that question then a lot
of other things in the world would be
solved already I suppose are we in a
computer simulation I I don't know I
guess I wish I I suppose I guess I don't
know if that's an important question
because the answering that question
results in a better reality in no way so
I don't I think I'm notice I'm more
interested in in like bettering our
world then then answering whether or not
worsen maybe we are simulation but does
it matter we still we are still going to
care about the same things does that
make sense
it matters to expand ones awareness
about the possibility the final yes or
no also matters but that's a longer
conversation but to expand ones
awareness around the conversation is
really important now so you're asking me
whether I take that ID pill or the blue
pill essentially is is the question or
is that your next question is that those
he's those are great answers that
question red pill red pill
okay how about last last thought is what
is your what are your thoughts about the
consciousness or the soul moving from
body to body over time in the past and
the present in the future what are your
thoughts about that so I suppose this is
a question on a potential afterlife and
whether the soul is atra is a
transcendent property that exists
outside of the body it's a great way to
phrase that question is the soul
transcendent property that's a yeah is
it well I mean I don't know if there's
any scientific evidence that suggests
that it is I think if you were to hold
that belief at this point then you would
be that that belief would exist on faith
it wouldn't necessarily exist it's a
nice some feelings oh right you do get
these feelings of living in past bodies
feelings of living in past bodies I have
no idea worked out what those feelings
my I I think I think in many ways
describing an experience to you from a
hundred or five hundred or a thousand
years ago they're describing experience
through your reading about it you're
watching them we're watching you're
living in it virtually and then you're
realizing that wow I lived in those
shoes whether it be the collective
consciousness or the individual
consciousness but wow wow that sounds
like an experience that I'd love to have
it if you could if you could educate me
aboard your life 5,000 years ago maybe I
would I would I would discover mine but
I guess the the way I view it is is this
in in many ways we we like asking these
questions because we don't fully trust
that the beauty of the human experience
can be continued
within this human brain and I guess I
would challenge that assumption so why
is it nor is it entirely not possible
that we can that everything we
experience and all of the wonderful
things that happen to us throughout life
can all stem from just simple neural
mechanisms that are explainable yep
there's it does it do we need to super
do we need to impose fantasies like do
we need a higher explanation is isn't
isn't it good enough to understand the
human brain and would you would you
believe would you potentially believe
that everything that human beings
experience just comes from the brain
including including the concept of a
soul probably some from the heart maybe
even some from other organs inside of
our body yeah and then furthermore where
else does the experience of the soul
come from then that's another one of our
questions about about consciousness
about it being localized here in the
body or if it's in other places as well
so wow what a great session what a great
conversation it's been such a pleasure
like thank you so much thank you so much
and we covered so much everything from
you know lost in transition all the way
to the future of video games and why and
why it's so important to understand all
the potential that video game design and
development has in useful applications
in today's world and virtual reality AI
so in their simulation questions at the
end what a blast
thank you the potential that we are all
living in a video game right now yeah
and the creators really loving the
creators are really observing us and the
process of seeing what their creation is
doing so are we going to nuke ourselves
to death or are we going to sustain and
colonize the cosmos let's let's do the
ladder please so alright thank you
everyone for tuning in if you had a good
time please give us a like comment below
your thoughts about what was going on
subscribe share share the content with
other people and make sure to become a
patron we have a patreon account you get
great exclusive benefits of becoming a
patron supporting our studio supporting
our guests all this good stuff we'll be
announcing our live event coming up
either in April or May soon so stay
tuned that's gonna be exciting Ron
Vargas thank you our producer and
director and to our family offices that
support us as well thank you everyone
and we'll talk to you again soon see ya